categorize the following triangles
according to whether they're whether or
not they are obtuse triangles so an
obtuse triangle is a triangle that has
an obtuse angle in it or an angle that
is larger than 90 degrees so it's pretty
clear that this one does not have any
obtuse angles this is a 90 degree angle
and then these are going to have to be
less than 90 degrees so this is not
obtuse this one right over here just by
looking at it you see that all of them
are less than 90 degrees so I'll put
this not obtuse now these two are
interesting angle JKL looks like it is
larger than 90 degrees and we can assume
that these are drawn to scale so we can
base it on our kind of visual judgment
so I would say that this is obtuse and
Bango angle BAC also looks like it is
larger than 90 degrees so that's an
obtuse angle so I would throw that in
the obtuse bucket as well so we had to
not up twos to obtuse
check our answer let's do a couple more
of these which of the following are
correct descriptions of triangle P IG or
I guess triangle pig select all that
apply P IG is equilateral well that's
not true to be equilateral all the sides
have to be the same length and you see
here two sides or seven but one side has
length 4 so that's not true
angle P IG has two equal angles well we
see that right over here 74 these two
angles that are 74 degrees so that's
true angle triangle P triangle pig I
kiss has an obtuse angle well an obtuse
angle is one that's larger than 90
degrees none of these are larger than 90
that's not true
triangle Pio ji has three acute angles
well that is true all of these angles
are less than 90 degrees triangle P IG
has a right angle no none of these
angles are exactly 90 degrees so it
isn't or it is not does not have a right
angle so let's check our answer let's do
one more of this is actually kind of fun
categorize the following triangles
according to whether or not they are
equilateral so to be equilateral all of
the sides have to have the same length
so this is equilateral this one the
sides are definitely not the same length
in fact not even two of the sides are
the same like that it's really a scalene
triangle here we have two sides that are
the same lengths but the third is
different this would be an
Solly's triangle but it's not
equilateral and here they're all the
same length so we have an equilateral
triangle we got it right